[музика]
Привіт друзі Усім привіт з вами
майстерня творчості пані солі та єсенка
Сьогодні будемо вчитися малювати жирафу
Давайте покажемо які плямки в жирафки
плямки плямки плямки плямки плямки
плямки плямки от будемо вчитися малювати
дуже просто малювати перше що нам
потрібно це звичайно що аркуш паперу
будь що що пише Або малює і починаю Отож
істинку малюємо
такий овал це буде голова
далі малюємо таку шийку дві лінії вниз
Добре тепер малюємо тіло
шийка може бути до речі довша Як ви собі
друзі захочете так і малюєте
хай буде довше
як в динозавра диплодок
далі малюємо ось тут таку лінію
далі малюємо два вушка
А можна по-іншому вушка намалювати як
собі захочеш але спочатку вушка а потім
трішки Ну але Гаразд малюю як тобі
подобається
але є ще окремо вушка і окремо ріжки
малюю вушко я тоді домальовую ріжки Ось
так є
далі малюємо хвостик
далі малюємо 4 ніжки
добре або Ось так Та можна Що так як ти
її ставку намалювала я раз за тобою
повторю Я тепер малюємо ніздрі і ротик
жираф кадихає
оченята
в мене дівчинка жирафка супер І
наприкінці що ще має жирафка
плямки малюємо плямки плямки плямки
плямки плямки плямки зі всіх боків
плямки
п'янки п'янки п'янки п'янки
вже раки багато плямок зробіть багато
Ось так моя жирафка готова
і ще на ножках треба ой до речі на
ніжках треба плямки справді бачите
щодо малювати такими смужками знизу
просто
яку
Ось так друзі у нас вийшло
жирафка я щось трошки тут ще одну
волосинку намалюю бо я
волоссячко А моя жирафка вже готова ось
так
Ну що ж малюйте своїх жирафак
папа
[музика]
Привіт малята з вами пані Софія і
звичайно мої помічники пригадуєте хто
звісно юстинка і зайченя хрумчик і
Сьогодні ми з вами послухаємо дуже
цікаву історію
але спочатку я хочу щоб ви послухали що
це за музичний інструмент грає
[музика]
правда красиво
ви напевно здогадались що це це піаніно
а наша історія буде теж про такий
музичний інструмент А хто на ньому
навчився грати ви зараз дізнаєтесь Ну ми
починати я вже вмію на ньому грати клас
це дуже круто
одного разу Ведмежа знайшло у лісі щось
цікаве Чого ніколи раніше не бачило
цікаво що це за дивна штукенція подумала
воно
і боязку доторкнулося до неї
пан із дивної штукенції пролунав
жахливий звук
і ведмежа пішло собі
але наступного дня Воно повернулося і ще
через день також повернулося
воно грало на цьому музичному
інструменті
днями тижнями і навіть роками
проходили різні пори року Давайте
пригадаємо зараз нас весна далі
літо
наступна пора року осінь і зима
Ось так наша Ведмежа грало на цьому
музичному інструменті грало а звуки Що
лунали з цієї дивної штуканьці стали
прекрасними а саме Ведмежа а виросло у
великого і дуже ведмедя коли Ведмідь
грав то почувався дуже щасливим звуки
ніби переносили його з рідного лісу до
далеких і дивних країв які він бачив у
своїх мріях
от невдовзі до звичайної галявини на у
лісі почали приходити інші ведмеді що
мешкали у цьому лісі
щовечора там збирався великий натовп
охочих послухати Чарівні мелодії які
Ведмідь награвав на цій дивній штукенці
І от одного вечора на галявину натрапила
дівчинка вона розповіла ведмедику що
дивно штукенція це є піаніно а звуки які
він награє називаються музикою
Поїхали з нами до міста сказала дівчинка
там так багато музики ти зможеш грати на
славетних інструментах перед сотнями
слухачів і почуєш такі прекрасні звуки
а ведмідь знав якщо він поїде інші
ведмеді дуже за ним будуть сумувати
проте наш ведмедик прагнув побачити світ
поза межами лісу і послухати дивовижну
музику навчитися справді майстерно грати
на піаніно тому невдовзі
ведмедеве ім'я красувалось у світлі
яскравих софітів великого і яскравого
міста
До речі юстинку ти знаєш що таке софіти
не знаю малята софіти - це таке
оформлення будинків або залів для
кращого освітлення і от наш Ведмідь
збирав цілі аншлаги у величезних театрах
тобто на його концерт хотіли усі
розкупити квитки щоб скоріше почути як
майстерно ведмедик виконує музику на
музичному інструменті
щовечора він грав так пристрасно і так
захоплюється що слухачі Купали його в
оваціях тобто плескали йому і щиро
захоплювались ведмедиком
Ведмідь записував альбоми давав інтерв'ю
для журналів здобував винагороди щодня
він зустрічав нових людей і де б не
потрапляв Усі знали хто він
але велике місто виявилося саме таким як
і сподівався ведмедик
десь на дні його серце ви знаєте друзі
оселилась туга А чому Як ви думаєте у
нього були слава
винагороди його знали всі-всі-всі але
він сумував за своїм рідним лісом і за
своїми давніми друзями
Отож Ведмідь вирішив повернутись назад
до лісу він квапливо перетнув річку і
радісно пострибав до лісу він просто не
міг дочекатися коли розповість своїм
друзям про своє життя у великому місті
та коли Ведмідь дістався до знайомої
галявини там було порожньо ні піаніно ні
ведмедів
анічогісінько Ведмідь розхвилювався що
його друзі забули про нього або ж
Гніваються за те що він їх покинув
Аж ось на галявину вийшов один із його
приятелів Привіт вигукнув Ведмідь я
повернувся я так сумував за вами але не
сказавши ні слова сіренький Ведмідь
знову гайнув до лісу
Зачекай скрикнув Ведмідь піаніст Зачекай
Я шкодую що поїхав звідси будь ласка
зупинись але його приятель просто побіг
далі що ж було далі Ведмідь пошкондибав
за ним і заходив у ліс усе глибше та
глибше і раптом побачив те що змусило
його шерсть стати дибки
Хм що це означає тобто сталось така чого
він не сподівався зустріти і побачити
він побачив своє піаніно і не лише
піаніно
він побачив своїх друзів вони не
гнівались на нього а пишалися ним і тут
Ведмідь зрозумів де б він не був Що він
не робив друзі завжди думали про нього і
підтримували його навіть так далеко
навіть у лісі вони навіть заховали
піаніно у затінок і оберігали його до
ведмедевого повернення
тож після того як ведмідь розповів своїм
друзям про життя у місті про усі його
концерти які йому випало зіграти Він
всім за піаніно щоб зіграти і ще один
концерт цього разу для найважливіших у
світі слухачів для його друзів от така
Лісова пригода трапилася і з ведмедиком
який знайшов у лісі піаніно навчився на
ньому грати
і радісно радісно грав для друзів для
всього світу а тепер малята я хочу вас
запитати чи є у вас музичний інструмент
який ви найбільше любите істинку У тебе
є якісь улюблений музичний інструмент
електрогітара Вау Круто ти би хотіла на
ній навчитись грати та я би хотіла бо я
люблю
рок-н-рол Ух ти це такий напрям у музиці
рок-н-ролл дуже класно а друзі у мене
для вас є завдання
[музика]
Намалюйте малюнок із Вашим улюбленим
інструментом і одразу можете придумати
історію хто на ньому буде грати
наприклад собачка на барабанах Або я ще
люблю як звучить саксофон або ви справді
Можливо ви хочете на чомусь навчитись
грати на якомусь музичному інструменті
тоді Намалюйте це ну що ж а ми будемо
прощатися з вами були пані Софія і мої
помічники друзі Зайченя хрумчик і
юстинка па-па
[музика]